I wanted to be documented the first time
I ever pull a card of me in it it's a
super insane
[Music]
so many people were asking me like how
how do I live my dream Gary and you know
I don't have time I've mortgages and
bills and responsibilities of my job and
I'm time for my side hustle my twitch
channel my Instagram account my Shopify
store selling pretties and I keep
getting to this new place which is talk
to me about your bills like why'd you
buy an apartment that stretches you why
is your car so fancy like why do you
need the new Gucci every time like why
are you why are you going out Thursday
Friday and Saturday night like why are
you going to Coachella like why why are
you going to a vengers opening night and
buying the biggest piece of popcorn and
candy like the answer to all of your
questions is not how much money you make
or how much time you have it's what
you're spending your money on
I love your slimy video it's amazing
thank you I decided to write you need to
think about what other people think of
you Ernie if that you're dumb you say
okay okay
[Music]
you're the smartest girl here give me a
hug thank you
[Applause]
what is your [ __ ] problem I'm tired
of talking about people having the
ability to tune out the negatives I'm
done telling you to not worry about
haters and trolls and negative opinions
I'm actually flipping the [ __ ] script
on you and I'm gonna yell at and I'm
gonna push at and I'm just gonna try to
inspire or communicate a perspective for
you to stop hearing the cheering the
reason so many struggle with negativity
is because they over value positive
reinforcement
you're addicted to people telling you
you're pretty you're addicted to people
telling you you're good at basketball
you're addicted to parents and teachers
telling you you're a good student
you're addicted to opinions
once you learn how to not overvalue
somebody who's commending or
complimenting you is the second you go
down the path AB dealing with the
reverse what people don't understand is
how much work I put to even begin the
process of being Who I am today 2007
2011 is a long time ago for a lot of
people that year I decided to go on
Twitter search and anybody that talked
about wine I jumped in and talked to
them how did I get here
hand-to-hand combat give me your phone
let me show you something so you go to
Columbia Maryland place you go to places
right so I'm in internet search right
judge this is gonna work for all of you
if you want to build so you just go to
Columbia Maryland and right now it's
gonna show you all the top photos and
all the recent photos what I did but on
Twitter with the word Pinot Noir is that
you literally and look
instagrams add a little bit of a
different place the first photos like a
dude who's like lookin real [ __ ]
diesel and [ __ ] and so like I mean you
could you could like and this I'm not
joking I would literally go in here be
like swole post I did this look there's
a couple good things going for you one
your name is realtor bright like like
the fact this is how I think right I
think right I think your kid is good and
again look like what's gonna be
unpopular attractive people so as a guy
it's a pretty girl you don't want to
come across great you got to be
thoughtful you don't have to go to every
post but you go to these posts right and
like this is happening in these posts
are happening in this town right like
for example here's something about she
want Wegmans right literally you're like
love that I'm doing it right for you
right now because I don't think people
get it love that place right so I want
you to become the mayor of the town I
did when I just showed you for four
hours five hours six hours a day on
Twitter if I was nobody which is 99% of
people now I don't have a million
followers I'm trying to grow I'm trying
to build my dreams and aspirations
literally doing what I just showed you
or 10 hours ago
[Music]
yeah I know it's possible of course it's
possible millions of people do it the
question is are you hungry enough and
willing to [ __ ] eat [ __ ] or are you
soft no I believe I'm I believe I'm
willing to do it because I know
following you I hear that you know eat
[ __ ] and I feel like people that you
know unless maybe they got a stroke of
just complete luck you know that's what
they at least have to eat [ __ ] a little
bit everybody ain't my man every single
person that's made it they made it they
ate [ __ ] and did the work there's people
that inherited money there's people that
have won the lottery let's stop thinking
about those people everybody spends all
their time thinking about those people
those people are enigmas they're
anomalies they're two point zero zero
zero zero one percent they have nothing
to do with you yeah the 99.999 that made
something of themselves ate [ __ ] they
put in the work
you're right I know I'm right
everybody's fixated on [ __ ] 4,000
people while there's seven point seven
billion people who [ __ ] worked or
didn't and then failed you want to be an
actor get your ass to [ __ ] LA yeah
what do you mean here start you don't
know anybody [ __ ] of course you know
somebody tweet and then some my now be
like who's in LA you know who's in LA
your former teammates [ __ ] sister
your [ __ ] friend from high schools
uncle people are no lie you know [ __ ]
30 people in LA you haven't [ __ ]
asked yeah I know you're not this yeah
here I did I know I'm late dude
and I wanted for you no I appreciate
this and the best part is you might suck
[ __ ] adapting but you need to find that
out yeah get your [ __ ] North Carolina
ass to LA take Ashley with you and
[ __ ] go live your [ __ ] life don't
[ __ ] buy into an antiquated process
you can act tomorrow
[Music]
couple things you've made enough content
with not enough use where my normal talk
of like you're being impatient goes out
the window
you are definitely at this point not
making content that's connecting and
that doesn't listen to me listen to me
that doesn't need to be devastating like
oh [ __ ]
nobody likes me or I suck that needs to
be how do I make different content maybe
you need to do a talk show format maybe
you need to you understand don't dwell
that that's happening but you definitely
need to mix something up with your
content you got to try different [ __ ]
because you've done enough you're
telling me that you've done 300 videos
and they still only get 20 or 30 views
but for the most part it's really tough
to give this advice because it almost
comes across as hurting one's feelings
but on the flip I'm actually excited
about it you are very rare
you've gone hard enough long enough
around a certain way that you've given
me the opportunity to give a rare advice
which is hey you can't do that [ __ ] no
more
you have to completely switch it up that
has been proven to me with those numbers
as it does not work
you have to you can first of all it's
great that you have that when you're 59
where you're 95 you're gonna love seeing
16 year old yeah I love seeing right now
it right it's cool no I don't think you
have to I think you just need to come
out and be like I went to complex con I
saw Gary Vee this is the video he told
me you switched it up my next video is
gonna be switching it up and that video
becomes the one that starts the new
chapter
hopefully my bosses until they let me in
and out boss the in and out pause
sorry you could you can go work in
jack-in-the-box [ __ ] that
like I'm not worried about that yeah
we're not worried about the in-and-out
[ __ ] burger manager the jury drop you
through so that's we're not worried
about what I'm worried about is you
saying hey what I wanted to do doesn't
work yeah and as much as that hurts and
it hurts it hurts as much as that hurts
I'm gonna flip it up I'm being serious
like you're literally gonna live for
more lives five more like from the day
you were born that you cannot [ __ ]
remember - right this second you're
about to do that three to four more
times
you can sit literally literally your
biggest advantage is timing for all the
great things that I have in my life I
would literally give it up all of it all
of it just to be 25 I would give up for
17 years I'd give up everything I have
because that's how valuable time is and
the far majority of this room has time
time as their asset and every day the
number one asset they have time they
give away by being impatient mainly on
the back of listening to society or
their parents that they have to have
their [ __ ] figured out at this age the
fact that people actually think at
eighteen twenty-two or thirty you have
to have your [ __ ] figured out is [ __ ]
ridiculous let me promise you all those
parents and uncles and grandparents that
push down your throat that you have to
figure it out by now they still haven't
figured it the [ __ ] out
I mean it so this nonsense this [ __ ]
nonsense that you have to have it
figured out at eighteen twenty to thirty
you many people freak the [ __ ] out at
thirty
how many feeler thirty right now that
[ __ ] was crazy right
like people lose their [ __ ] at thirty
like meanwhile they're a [ __ ] kid
and so I'm unbelievably aware lately
that one of the you know people are just
like why do you when I talk about my
parents and not coming from anything but
the more that I live on like [ __ ] the
reason I really win is cuz I understand
time and listen I know I can get hit by
a bus or get terminally ill I get it
here's the problem that's far more
unlikely for the majority of us the math
works in your favor and we are
stunningly not paste it's funny how that
just went through my mind
I actually think being lazy is a good
thing let me explain this is gonna be
interesting moment ya know you're
freaking out right stop watching Netflix
is under the context of stop using
something to escape your real life if
you don't realize you're trying to
escape your real life don't use Netflix
or watching the New York let's get very
much into clarification on this episode
I watch the Jets or four hours on
Sundays I do that because it allows me
to escape and like it gives me balance
to my insanity but I don't watch the
Jets on Sunday to get away from the fact
that I hate my job and instead of doing
something like for my job I'm gonna use
this because Netflix is a
seven-day-a-week thing to Kay and for
night is a seven-day-a-week thing and it
even sports people that watch the
Yankees and the Mets and the Knicks and
the Jets the way I watch the Jets
that's why football worked for me one
day a week you know some people use
entertainment as a reset and a balance
to their other life which is work family
and then other people use Kanta you know
escapism as a way to just get by because
they hate their life and it's the way
for them not to have to think about it
right
laziness has my attention because I
think if you're lazy you're actually
giving yourself an indication that you
don't like it so I think laziness you
don't like what whatever the task at
hand for you you just prop I John you
appreciate this and I think you could
see in trash talk I mean I'm never d-roc
will tell you who's hangs out with me a
lot that between trash talk and the
baseball card show in Chicago he's never
seen me happier I get an incredible
thrill deep inherent happiness from
getting into a car on a 6 a.m. on a
Saturday and going to find something to
buy for 3 bucks and sell for 100 this is
not about the cliche [ __ ] that people
say my comments are like you didn't make
that much money was the gap you know
it's not all those things I love it
school I hate it I am lazy around
housework around logistics
I think quote unquote laziness can have
a more thoughtful conversation of
actually is it laziness or are you
showing yourself that you don't like
that thing and it becomes a mechanism to
self-awareness I think it's that I think
it's neat you don't baby the most
important thing I think about what I
think about getting to happiness is not
so much owning anything it's the ability
to not hear anything but yourself
[Music]
there's nothing more powerful than when
everything gets quiet and the only thing
that penetrates is your own voice and
that voice isn't judging you
when you look back now at the kid who
felt pressure or the kid who felt an
obligation what would you say to that
kid now
I would tell that kid to stay the course
because he's got to figure it out
tops series two released today and in
the packs of tops series 2 first time
I'm ever gonna see it and the back and
smoke I mean Jesus Christ this small
friend I'm getting old but in the packs
of top Series 2 is an insert card called
Gary B's top entrepreneurs in baseball
where there is a 12 card set we pick 12
guys and then there's so there's 12
cards different players 12 different
players you get one of those in every 18
pack so almost one or two in a box I
think that's going off the top my head
and then there's a dual Auto card where
you can get an autograph of me and the
player there's a in one of these packs
for example I could pull right now I
know it's more than 5,000 packs they do
a lot of right I'm gonna try to pull a
card of myself I wanted to be documented
the first time I ever pull a card of me
in it there it is Jose Ramirez geremy's
top I cannot believe I just pulled it
was so awesome how insane is this I am
literally on a [ __ ] baseball card are
you [ __ ] kidding me
that was so [ __ ] cool
[Music]
and you want to move to New York let's
do it
[Applause]
Oh
bring the [ __ ] bell
[Applause]
I always play this out let's say when
you go to heaven they can show you what
would have happened because that's the
only way you'd ever see let's just say
what people don't understand it oh yeah
you made the wrong call you should have
went to grad school instead of that
opportunity where in this company
instead of that company but you'll never
believe it you should have went to
vaynermedia and it was perfect
and you rose like a phoenix and you were
the head of all sound and everything
went great but then you had to go to
Virginia on business and you got hit by
a car and you died a31 that's life
[Music]
I passed on uber as an investor twice in
the beginning if I did my normal
twenty-five fifty thousand dollar check
I would have made four hundred million
dollars which means I might have went to
China for a keynote two years ago which
means I could've got hit by a [ __ ]
bus I really believe in that [ __ ] you
just don't know you think you know but
that is not how life works
so to like look at to ideas and think
you can practically make a good decision
is laughable
[Music]
literally flip a coin just pick the one
that feels better right that second and
make it about you because usually what
kids struggle with is the decision they
want to do versus the decision that they
think they're supposed to do based on
the other voices think about this if you
grew up loving and flipping sneakers and
one day you had your own signature
sneaker that's what these cards are for
me this has literally been the best week
of my life really yeah man this is just
like I'm like literally sad that it's
Saturday night like I don't do five days
of anything
d-roc will tell you I fly to give a
speech in Hawaii and fly back I'm there
for four minutes like I never stay
anywhere ever I wish I could live here
for the next year this is as good as it
gets
[ __ ] Wednesday who said 100 faces a
cab yeah what a baseball great show yeah
lot going on I love you
you